Juez: Habitual.
Juez: Si instala la audiencia programada para el día de hoy, dentro del proceso
Juez: proceso laboral de pago de salarios devengados y otros, seguido por el demandante Gutenberg, montaño, es Company, en contra del gobierno autónomo municipal de Santa Rosa de Laguna por Secretaría informa sobre las notificaciones y la presencia de las partes.
SECRETARIA- ABG. BLANCA MASHIEL CARVAJAL MITA: La palabra. Señora juez, se informa que el expediente no se encontraría al corriente, toda vez que no ha sido notificado a la parte demandante. Sin embargo, por secretaría, se ha enviado a la Comisión instruida en fecha. Doce de de noviembre.
SECRETARIA- ABG. BLANCA MASHIEL CARVAJAL MITA: la misma se ha contactado con el teniente que está a cargo del jefe cantonal de la Policía de Santa Rosa. El mismo me indica que ha recogido la Comisión instruida. Sin embargo, no lo ha podido diligenciar a razón de que la carretera se encuentra en mal estado
SECRETARIA- ABG. BLANCA MASHIEL CARVAJAL MITA: en ese sentido no está presente. La parte demandada, sin embargo, se encuentra presente el demandante. El señor Guttenberg, conjuntamente con su abogado doctor Amielcal beltrán es en cuanto a información.
Juez: Tiene presente el informado por la Secretaría.
Juez: evidentemente, de la verificación de las actuales marinos procesal.
Juez: La condición estrida adjunta no tiene constancia de que se hubiera notificado la parte demandada. En ese sentido, tiene la palabra el abogado de la parte demandante.
Amilcar Beltrán I.: Muchas gracias, señora Jueza, una pequeña antes por antes de intervenir esa diligencia, que se comisión instruida que se envió a la localidad de
Amilcar Beltrán I.: de Santa Rosa es para con el señalamiento de la audiencia.
Juez: Podría ampliar la información la Comisión que se enviado la notificación a la parte demandada?
Juez: ¿qué documentación has adjuntado.
SECRETARIA- ABG. BLANCA MASHIEL CARVAJAL MITA: La palabra, señora juez, se informa que ha sido adjuntado el auto de apertura de la etapa de prueba y todas las audiencias que han sido suspendidas. Y la última en la que se señala la audiencia para este presente.
Juez: Usted tiene presente el informado con la secretaría
Juez: conforme a los antecedentes del cuaderno que usa la roja, 104 donde se ha aperturado la etapa probatoria
Juez: si se ha dispuesto a notificarse a la parte demandada. Con dicha resolución.
Amilcar Beltrán I.: Ya. Muchas gracias. Muchas gracias, señora Jueza
Amilcar Beltrán I.: en en en el entendido de que no está corriente el presente expediente. Solicitamos que se pueda oficiar a la policía para que se dé cumplimiento a esta resolución judicial de citación
Amilcar Beltrán I.: y de esa manera también se fija una nueva audiencia y tengo entendido de que hay un defensor de oficio para que se haga presente y se lo notifique al Defensor de oficio para que esta audiencia no se pueda suspender en la próxima fecha. Señora juez.
Juez: Se tiene presente lo manifestado por el abogado de la parte demandada perdón de la parte demandante
Juez: ante la falta de diligencia de la parte, demandar a sí mismo ante la inasistencia de un abogado de oficio para el presente acto judicial
Juez: y para no causar intervención de la parte demandada, toda vez que no se encuentra el abogado de oficio en la presente audiencia, corresponde suspender la presente audiencia y programarse una nueva fecha. De acuerdo a nuestra agenda del posgrado.
Juez: conforme la verificación de la agenda de las audiencias del Estado
Juez: y no tenemos espacio ya para este mes.
Juez: Así mismo, informar a la parte demandante que presenten audiencia que por resolución de la sala Pleno. Número 35, quebrado 2 024 han des dispuesto vacaciones judiciales colectivas
Juez: a partir del día, martes, 9 de diciembre, hasta el 2 de enero, 2 025.
Juez: Considerando
Juez: las vacaciones colectivas, no tenemos suficiente espacio para programar la presente audiencia para esta gestión. En este caso tendríamos que reprogramar para la gestión 2 026.
Amilcar Beltrán I.: La palabra, señora este mes, que no tiene espacio, pero tenemos hasta el mes de diciembre doctora. Podrías señalarse hasta el
Amilcar Beltrán I.: tenemos desde el lunes 5 hasta el viernes hasta el martes 9 de diciembre, podríamos señalar esa fecha doctora. No podíamos dilatar tanto tiempo. Imagínese el perjuicio que le va a causar al en la demora procesal.
Juez: Se tiene presente lo manifestado y vamos a considerar: vamos a verificar nuestra vida nuevamente a
Juez: El día. Lunes, 1, 2, 3. Ya tenemos agendadas las audiencias.
Juez: Podría ser para el día. Lunes, 8 de diciembre.
Amilcar Beltrán I.: A qué hora doctora podría ser.
Juez: A horas 2 de la tarde y 30
Juez: de viento, notificarse a la parte demandada y al abogado de oficio
Juez: queda notificada. La parte demandante presente en la audiencia.
Amilcar Beltrán I.: Ahora hagamos una una aclaración doctora. Tenemos que notificar al Defensor de oficio, no claro para que así ya.
Juez: Donde se ha aperturado la etapa probatoria donde se ha declarado.
Juez: revela la parte demandada. En la resolución se ha dispuesto a notificarse a la parte demandada con esa resolución y
Juez: sí, para que en el futuro la parte demandada no aleguen disfunción o falta de notificación corresponde no más notificarse a la parte demandada con esa resolución, donde se ha declarado reunión
Juez: y complementando por secretaría expidas en nueva condición instruida y contiene con la parte demandante a que la misma pueda.
Amilcar Beltrán I.: Yo creo que es una exageración de su parte doctora con la palabra y creo que una exageración nuevamente una Comisión instruida, toda vez de que en 2 procesos judiciales son la demanda, la rebeldía y
Amilcar Beltrán I.: la sentencia para notificarse. Cuando se tiene un defensor de oficio, yo creo que estaríamos ya
Amilcar Beltrán I.: sobrepasando lo que es el el el tema de la indefensión, porque no hay indefensión, porque usted ya designó defensor de oficio, entonces yo le le acepto la primera Comisión con la rebeldía pero nuevamente doctora. Imagínese
Amilcar Beltrán I.: que nosotros podamos diligenciar una una nueva diligencia sólo para que tiene audiencia con dieta declarado rebelde.
Juez: No, no, no, no, claro, Doctor.
Juez: la claro doctor en la que le mencionabas, toda vez que la la condición instruida que ha sido expedida no ha sido devuelta aclarando doctor. No estoy disponiendo nueva condición, es, me me refiero a la Comisión, que, por secretaría que informó que ella fue expedida.
Juez: Me refiero a eso. Entonces tendría que coordinar ya la comisión instruida, que ha sido ya expedida, que es el número 56, 2 025.
Amilcar Beltrán I.: Está bien, está aclarado. Entonces, hasta luego.
Juez: Okay, doctor, no habiendo más que consideras en la presente audiencia, se concluye la misma.